madame monsieur bonsoir il y à 61 ans
exactement le 11 novembre 1918
s'achevait la première guerre mondiale
comme chaque année cet anniversaire qui
était également cette fois-ci l'occasion
d'honorer tous les morts pour la france
au cours des différents combats pour son
indépendance a été marquée par de
nombreuses cérémonies a commencé ce
matin par celle des champs elysées à
paris présidée par le chef de l'état
monsieur giscard d'estaing le
commentaire de léon zitrone l'arc de
triomphe et les champs elysées des
baigné de soleil quand le président de
la république arrive à pour passer la
revue des troupes notamment celle des
combats 39 40
après s'être incliné devant le drapeau
de la gendarmerie mobile
le chef de l'état a écouté la
marseillaise
oui
nombre des régiments présents avaient
combattu et à narvik qui à saumur en
somme les premiers et les derniers
grands combats de la campagne 39 40
avant le renouveau que vous lui de
gaulle
le chef de l'état déposa une gerbe de
roses rouges sur le tombeau de l'inconnu
il avait été accompagné jusque là par le
premier ministre le ministre de la
défense et celui des anciens combattants
puis le président devait remettre leur
drapeau au régiment d'infanterie de la
garde républicaine qui sont désormais au
nombre de deux
colonel gérardin au nom de la france
je vous remets le drapeau du 1er
régiment d'infanterie de la garde
républicaine
ce devait être suivie par une remise de
décorations notamment à des veuves de
guerre madame marie françoise de bushman
preuve de guerre nous vous faisons
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
la journée était dédiée à la mémoire de
tous ceux qui tombèrent dans tous les
combats auxquels la france a pris part
au pouvoir demeurer libre et
indépendante
le public fut très chaleureux au
monument de traitement sont morts il y à
tout juste 50 ans en novembre 29 et
avant les cérémonies prévues pour la fin
de ce mois à mouilleron-en-pareds ce
site et la table monsieur raymond barre
déposé une couronne de fleurs au pied de
celui dont l'énergie indomptable avait
permis de continuer la guerre 14-18 au
pire moment et de la gagne
oui après les cérémonies de ce matin le
président de la république participe est
un déjeuner au château de vincennes
repas offert un millier de vols de
guerre devant lesquelles monsieur
giscard d'estaing a prononcé un discours
à double portée portée politique d'abord
le président a fait allusion aux
affaires qui troublent actuellement le
climat politique dans notre pays
mais d'abord il a annoncé des mesures en
faveur des veuves de guerre jean louis
de cette unité nationale 11 novembre
oblige solidarité entre les français ce
sont les deux thèmes développés par le
chef de l'état ici au château de
vincennes
au cours de cette rencontre avec les
veuves de guerre aujourd'hui encore la
face contre 315 mille veuves de guerre
de toutes les guerres et quatre mille
orphelins
tout comme il ya un mois à bordeaux
devant le congrès des veuves civiles
valéry giscard d'estaing a insisté sur
la nécessité de revaloriser et de
consolider la situation matérielle de
ceux qui ont eu à subir la perte d'un
mari ou d'un père après avoir rappelé
qu'en cinq ans le pouvoir d'achat du
minimum vieillesse a été augmentée de
50%
le président de la république a confirmé
qu'une assurance veuvage sera créée l'an
prochain pour faciliter la réinsertion
sociale des bobs de moins de 55 ans pour
les familles de trois enfants monsieur
giscard d'estaing a confirmé par
ailleurs qu'un revenu minimum de 3500
francs par mois serait institué enfin le
chef de l'état a annoncé que les veuves
de guerre sous certaines conditions
verraient leur passion augmenté en 1981
en conclusion valéry giscard d'estaing a
insisté sur les valeurs collectives les
valeurs morales que chacun at il dit
doit être attentif à respecter et à
défendre et il ne pouvait pas à cette
occasion ne pas évoquer en demi teinte
le climat politique actuel
la france comme les autres pays traverse
des temps difficiles générateur
d'inquiétude et de tensions dans ces
temps difficiles il est possible à
chacun de défendre ses idées ou même de
critiquer une politique sans rabaisser
le débat un niveau
indigne de la france le peuple qui porte
en lui les valeurs collectives qui font
la france c'est bien tout cela il
souhaite en réponse à la liberté qui est
et qui restera notre règle
la mesure la droiture et le respect oui
à propos de l' affaire boulin le
syndicat national des journalistes qui
s'est réuni à paris aujourd'hui estime
que les attaques contre la presse et son
rôle dans cette affaire ont mis en
évidence l'objectif que certains
poursuivent restreindre une des libertés
fondamentales et lui interdire sa
fonction le témoignage ce sont les
termes du communiqué du snj déjà à deux
candidats déclarés à la présidence de la
république en 1981 ils ne perdent pas de
temps deux candidats d'extrême droite
monsieur le pen président du front
national et monsieur pascal gauchos qui
représentera lui le parti les forces
nouvelles vous savez que le président de
la république doit prochainement
entreprendre un voyage dans le sud ouest
et que les trois présidents de conseils
généraux socialistes ont décidé à la fin
de ma semaine dernière de pratiquer la
politique de la chaise vide et bien ce
ne sera pas le cas de monsieur robert
fabre le maire de villefranche de
rouergue qui lui recevra monsieur
giscard d'estaing et qui estime comme il
l'a dit sur france inter aujourd'hui que
le dialogue ne veut pas dire forcément
ralliement ou rapprochement la cgt ne
pourra résister longtemps à cette
politique de non union avec la cfdt
c'est ce qu'a déclaré à rtl aujourd'hui
monsieur edmond maire pour lui les
militants communistes de la cgt sont
pris entre deux feux entre la volonté
unitaire du syndicat et l'attitude de
leur parti dans ces conditions le
secrétaire général de la cfdt
s'interroge et se demande si l'accord
d'unité d'action qui avait été conclu
avec la cgt au mois de septembre va
pouvoir tenir une nouvelle attaque donc
de la cfdt contre ce qu'elle considère
comme l' influence grandissante du parti
communiste sur la cgt réponse immédiate
ce soir de monsieur georges séguy qui
participait au club de presse je trouve
que
le secrétaire général de la cfdt a la
fâcheuse propension de saisir toutes les
occasions durant lesquelles micro se
tend vers lui pour faire de l'anti
communisme est à cet égard je pense
qu'il se livre à une politisation de son
organisation syndicale qui va à
l'encontre de l'unité d'action
indépendantes autonomes tel que nous
l'avons toujours conçu et j'estime que
cela ne correspond pas à l'esprit dans
lequel nous avons proposé sur la base
des travaux du 40ème congrès de la cgt
une unité d'action dégager de ces
considérations de ces options de ces
pressions politiques partisanes
monsieur reproche également votre double
casquette politique et syndicale
je ne sais pas s'il me l'a reproché dans
les déclarations que vous faites mais
s'il l'a fait à nouveau
il n'a fait que reprendre un vieux vieil
argument archi usé qui est de longue
date
sans valeur et qui ne le fait l'objet
dans mon organisation syndicale de
d'aucune contestation
je considère que la personne du ministre
du travail n'a pas une grande importance
à la mesure où les chargés d'appliquer
la politique de son gouvernement
je n'imagine pas que le seul ministre
depuis ce sur le plan social faire autre
chose que ses prédécesseurs
voilà pourquoi je m'interdis de porter
un jugement sur la personne je considère
que c'est un nouveau ministre du travail
un de plus qui va être amenés à
appliquer la politique du gouvernement
giscard barre en relation étroite avec
monsieur ceyrac si je tiens compte de
son passé ou à la direction des
charbonnages de france
je me rends compte qu'il est arrivé dans
ses fonctions au moment où les mineurs
avait une situation de l'emploi encore
assez bien équilibré que tout cela s'est
détériorée qu'il a présidé à la
fermeture d'innombrables pied de mine
depuis la mine et qu'il a présidé à la
liquidation de dizaines de milliers
d'emplois de travailleurs du sous sol
vous l'a compris en dernière analyse
monsieur georges séguy faisait allusion
à monsieur matteoli qui est nouveau
ministre du travail et on lui demandait
ce qu'il en pense la semaine qui
commence demain sera marquée sur le plan
social par la continuation de plusieurs
conflits dont on voit mal comment ils
pourront se résoudre d'abord alstom les
négociations sont rompues mais lundi
après-midi de même les représentants
syndicaux des sans-droits paris pour
rencontrer la discussion pour un échange
de la direction pardon pour un échange
de contrôleurs aériens un dialogue de
sourds épreuve de force quelles que
soient les formules employées l'horizon
reste bouché ministère et syndicats
campent sur leurs positions
et toute cette semaine sera encore
marquée par des retards au décollage sur
tous les aéroports français
deux autres conflits sont aussi dans
l'impasse du soulier en haute loire où
après sept semaines de grève des
négociations reprennent demain il yal
usine rhône poulenc à le pont de claix
dans l'isère où la mission de
conciliation du directeur départemental
du travail
il a échoué alors que les 2500 salariés
ont arrêté le travail depuis le 19
octobre
on n'est pas très optimistes non plus à
propos de la discussion sur la durée du
travail qui doit reprendre jeudi entre
les syndicats et le cnpf le patronat en
effet pour l'instant les positions des
uns et des autres restent très éloignées
enfin la greffe d'un certain nombre de
techniciens de la sfp à perturber
quelques-uns des programmes du week-end
sur les différentes chaînes de
télévision à l'étranger statu quo dans
la sphère des otages de l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran
cela dit il ya tout de même eu plusieurs
décisions prises aujourd'hui qui n'ont
fait qu'accroître la tension entre les
etats-unis et l'iran dans l'ordre
chronologique d'abord la décision de
monsieur caractère d'expulser tous les
étudiants iraniens n'ayant pas d'un
statut réguliers sur le territoire
américain
une déclaration de monsieur bani sadr
l'homme fort du conseil de la révolution
qui estime qu' aucun compromis aucune
négociation n'est possible il faut que
le chat soit extradé pour qu'il soit
jugé
ainsi que le seront les états unis qui
toujours selon monsieur bani sadr était
jusqu'à la révolution
les véritables maîtres du pays de l'iran
aujourd'hui encore le nonce apostolique
en iran a été autorisé à visiter les
otages que vous voyez actuellement les
otages qui l'a trouvé moralement fatigué
il faut dire que cela fait maintenant
exactement une semaine jour pour jour
que ces 60 fonctionnaires américains
sont détenus en otage dans leur
ambassade
un reportage de notre envoyé spécial
philippe roche voici les hommes et les
femmes qui détiennent les otages
américains
ils sont une centaine étudiants
extrémistes pour la plupart fidèles à
100% de la gâteau la robine
il défie ainsi chaque matin dans la cour
de l'ambassade américaine les
encouragements de la foule afin de
montrer qu'ils sont décidés à tenir
jusqu'à ce qu'ils obtiennent
l'extradition du shah d'iran
fort des dernières déclarations
violemment anti américaine
de la révolution et de son nouvel homme
fort monsieur banny cider il défie de
leurs points l'amérique de jimmy carter
et veulent montrer ici qu'ils ont tout
le pays derrière ce projet tous ces gens
sont venus apporter leur soutien aux
étudiants pas seulement eux mais aussi
35 millions d'iraniens 70000 personnes
sont morts à cause de l'amérique
avant la révolution il cent mille
aujourd'hui sont encore dans les
hôpitaux
c'est l'oeuvre des amériques ils ne
peuvent rien faire d'autre que de nous
livrer le chat et après ça on nous non
plus avoir de relation avec eux qu'ils
du shabak 27 l'ambassade américaine à
téhéran est devenu aujourd'hui un
véritable lieu de pèlerinage de
rencontre on vient y lire les journaux
mureaux où se bousculent les slogans
contre l'impérialisme américain et les
hymne à l'ayatollah khomeini les
mauvaises langues parlent de la kermesse
américaines ou des délégations entières
d'ouvriers et de paysans iraniens
viennent crier leur haine envers les
états unis
l'embarras des religieux devant ce
mouvement qui prend de l'ampleur et
manifeste l'ayatollah lahouti le chef
des gardiens de la révolution explique à
la foule qui vient ici à la demande des
étudiants pour constater que les otages
sont bien traités il se garde de toute
surenchère mais n'interviendra pas pour
leur libération
une semaine après l'occupation de
l'ambassade américaine par les
extrémistes iranien on se demande quel
médiation pourra réussir celle des
palestiniens c'est peu probable
hassan el hani le représentant de lp
nous a confié que les palestiniens ont
eu aussi à lutter contre les américains
et on les voit mal négocié la libération
de 60 otages ici à l'ambassade
américaine
les ambassadeurs étrangers ils sont
venus ici simplement pour des raisons
humanitaires constater que les otages
étaient bien traités mais se refuse à
parler de médiation que reste-t-il alors
le vatican pour l'instant l'ayatollah
khomeiny a accepté de recevoir le
message du saint siège mais cela
s'arrête là on imagine mal la république
islamique
acceptant la médiation du vatican alors
que reste-t-il eh bien il faut le
reconnaître
une semaine après l'occupation de
l'ambassade américaine on reste encore
dans l'impasse totale
j'ajouterai simplement une information
est ce qu indique philippe rochot ce
soir l'ambassade de la république
fédérale allemande à téhéran demande à
tous ses ressortissants ils sont à peu
près de 2500 en iran de quitter le pays
regain de tension en israël et dans les
territoires occupés après l'arrestation
ce matin du maire de naplouse en
cisjordanie monsieur chaque cas est une
personnalité très proche des
palestiniens et de lp et son
incarcération a tout de suite provoqué
l'annoncé d'une grève générale d'à
générales dans les territoires occupés
et la démission de plusieurs maires
arabe qui quitteront effectivement leurs
fonctions le jour où le maire de
naplouse sera expulsé comme en ont
décidé les autorités
israël l'autre décision importante prise
aujourd'hui à jérusalem c'est l'adoption
d'un nouveau programme de colonies de
peuplement dans les territoires occupés
un projet qui a ajouté à l'arrestation
du maire
l'un pelouse risque de gêner encore un
peu plus les négociations entre israël
et l'égypte au tchad en bref on est
arrivé à un compromis aujourd'hui et un
gouvernement d'union nationale doit être
présenté ce soir toutes les tendances
politiques du pays sont tombées d'accord
après plusieurs mois de négociations la
situation mondiale actuelle est
incertaine voire plus que précaire dans
les pays en voie de développement c'est
la première conclusion de la conférence
de la fao l'organisation des nations
unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture qui se tient en ce moment
même à rome c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
des pays comme le cambodge connaissent
la famine pour des raisons de guerre
d'autres pays en paix courent les mêmes
risques ce qui est plus grave c'est le
cas à moyen terme de l'egypte qui pour
l'instant ne cultivent qu'une portion
infime de son territoire comme nous le
montre cette enquête de notre
correspondant au caire pires sert
pendant presque vingt ans sous nasser
l'egypte s'est efforcé de se doter
d'industrie lourde
il s'agissait de créer une classe
ouvrière pour trouver une solution à une
démographie incontrôlable autant que
pour justifier un socialisme alors
soutenu par moscou
les hommes ont donc décidé de quitter
les campagnes surpeuplée pour venir
s'entasser dans cette ceinture de misère
qui se voulait cité ouvrière modèle
autour des hauts fourneaux de éloigne
aujourd'hui se souvenant que son peuple
est avant tout paysan et que l'egypte
est un don du nil
anouar el sadate veut que l'agriculture
reprennent le pas sur l'industrie
retour en arrière ou retour à la raison
c'est fabuleux
mais ce n'est pas suffisant la
population agricole représente 50 % de
la population active totale et au rythme
actuel de croissance démographique
l'egypte devra en 1981 importé pour deux
milliards de dollars de nourriture
c'est un problème de famille qui
risquent de se poser une seule solution
accroître multiplier même la superficie
des terres cultivables qui le représente
encore aujourd'hui que 5 % de la surface
totale du pays
le reste c'est du désert la bataille
contre le dr est donc engagé tous
azimuts élargissement de la peine du
delta la basse egypte est déjà en cours
depuis longtemps à l'ouest grâce au
canal lasserre à l'est grâce au canal
d'ismaïlia des réseaux d'irrigation ont
été construits
les sols sont donc régulièrement arrosé
on a planté des arbres la stabilisation
des terrains et réalisé est assuré entre
le caire et alexandrie à l'ouest entre
le caire et ismaïlia à l'est le très
vastes étendues de terres sont
maintenant cultivables et on y effectue
une expérience encourageante de culture
et d'élevage
pense aussi aux autres régions que l'on
pourrait bonifier les oasis du désert
libyque vous ne pourrez amener de l'eau
du nil que par le trop-plein de touche
qui en amont du haut barrage sur le lac
nasser et cela seulement dans le cas
bien improbable d'une crue
exceptionnelle du nil
et puis il ya aussi le sinaï que
l'egypte est en train de récupérer et où
l'état voudrait d'établir deux millions
d'égyptiens d'ici à l'an 2000 mais dans
l'état actuel des choses tous ces
projets relèvent davantage d'une grande
espérance que d'une réalité proche ne
faut pas l'oublier le nil déverse chaque
année sur le soudan et sur l'egypte 52
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau 52
milliards de mètres cubes qui sont
partagées par accord précis entre les
deux pays
18 milliards est à réserver au soudan et
34 milliards à l'egypte dans ces
conditions techniques difficiles et
financières aussi on remballe comment
toutes ces difficultés pourront être
surmontées
l'egypte espère malgré tout parvenir à
accroître de 30 à 50% ses terres
cultivables pour se nourrir sur
elle-même c'est très ambitieux et en
même temps c'est trop peu c'est trop peu
tant que les bouches à nourrir
continueront à se multiplier à raison de
un million deux cent mille par an
c'est-à-dire au moins dix fois plus vite
que le 70 des terres sur lesquelles 80
millions d'égyptiens devront se nourrir
en l'an 2000 s'il faut une justification
à la paix elle est là histoire d'une
bavure
le terme n'est pas bien beau mais il est
maintenant consacrer cela s'est passé
vendredi soir près des temps prenons les
faits dans l'ordre un jeune homme d'une
vingtaine d'années accompagné de deux
camarades fait le plein de sa voiture
une 504 dans une station service
il paie par chèque et reprend sa route
après une discussion avec le pompiste
qui trouvent que ce chèque est mal écrit
soupçonneux le pompiste aussitôt après
le départ téléphone le signalement du
jeune homme et le numéro de la voiture à
la police des tempes une vérification
rapide officier révèle que la voiture a
été volée aussitôt une patrouille se met
en chasse et rattrape la 500 cas les
deux policiers en civil coince la
voiture l'un sort un pistolet
mitrailleur l'autre dégaine son revolver
qui braquent qu'ils braquent sur les
occupants soudain le coup part et touche
le conducteur qui ce soir est toujours
dans un état très grave
g dans cette affaire c'est que l'anc est
aussitôt entreprises va révéler qui
une erreur officier de la police la
voiture a effectivement été volés il y a
trois ans mais elle a été retrouvée
restitué à son propriétaire qui l'a
lui-même revendu au jeune homme qui a
été blessé vendredi soir
le policier qui a tiré ne s'expliquent
absolument pas comment le coup a pu
partir il n'a pu fournir aucun détail
sur les circonstances de son maître
toute la région de toronto au canada en
alerte depuis ce matin depuis qu'un
train convoyant des produits chimiques
très dangereux a déraillé que ces wagons
se sont mis à exploser les uns après les
autres
dominique top cinq wagons-citernes d'un
train canadien se dirigeant vers toronto
et qui transportait des produits
chimiques dangereux il déraillait puis
explosé tôt ce matin nouvelle explosion
a eu lieu durant l'après midi
et cette fois-ci presque tous les wagons
22 sur 25 ont pris feu dans les deux cas
on pouvait voir des flammes s'élever à
300 mètres de haut pour le moment il n'y
a eu aucun blessé
on craint toutefois encore l'explosion
de deux ou trois wagons
toute la journée les pompiers ont évacué
les habitants de la banlieue de toronto
et notamment 400 malades d'un hôpital se
trouvaient à un kilomètre de l'accident
pour l'instant près de vingt mille
personnes ont ainsi été évacuées
sécurité en matière nucléaire puisque
nous parlons de produits dangereux
choses dangereuses journal officiel
annonce la création au sein du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique d'une
agence pour la gestion des déchets
radioactifs un organisme qui sera donc
contrôlé par les pouvoirs publics
demain le journal d'antenne 2010 sera
retransmis en direct de la cité du
vatican
patrick lecocq et toute l'équipe
d'antenne 2010 nous présenterons les
merveilles artistiques des musées du
vatican dont le voici un avant-goût
nous sommes ici dans la chapelle sixtine
qui est un des endroits les mieux connus
du vatican du moins par les visiteurs
mais le vatican renferme bien d'autres
merveilles notamment dans les musées
doubs sera diffusée en direct d'un
dialogue à vous lire demain notre
journal de 13 heures vous pourrez voir
entre autres la fameuse transfiguration
dont on se demandait jusqu'à maintenant
s'il était bien l'oeuvre du seul raphaël
c'est aujourd'hui chose certaine vous
saurez pourquoi
et puis nous vous ouvrirons pour la
première fois grâce à victor vraiment
notre correspondant permanent rome les
portes jusqu alors tsehaye tenus
soigneusement fermées pendant les portes
donc du trésor du vatican vous pourrez
voir encore bien d'autres pièces
historiques fameuse qui font la gloire
du vatican du mois dans le domaine de
l'art rendez vous donc demain 13h pour
suivre le guide d'antenne 2 à rome
patrick le corre
rectification n'est pas trésor mais
12h45 enfant n'est pas un quart d'heure
près mais vaut mieux voir le début après
les merveilles du vatican d'autres
oeuvres tout aussi populaire peut-être
même plus puisqu'elles ne sont pas
enfermés dans des musées mais qu'on peut
les voir tous les jours dans les rues de
toutes les villes de france je parlais
de ces immenses fresques qui surmonte
l'entrée des cinémas elles sont l'oeuvre
de peintres anonyme mais qui n'en sont
pas moins des artistes à leur façon
comme nous l'expliquent toujours louis
doucet
on les avait d'abord rappelé étoiles et
puis ils se sont pris lui et parce
qu'ils refont le monde chaque mercredi
ils appellent cela change et de
programmes les michel-ange du quotidien
employés à leur gloire refonte eux aussi
chaque semaine par nécessité le plafond
de ses multiples chapelle sixtine que
sont les frontons des temples du
septième art ainsi dans ce vaste atelier
de montreuil proche de celui où méliès
tourner ses films
ainsi la génèse prend tel par habitude
le rythme du mouvement perpétuel
on commencement était le verbe et le
verbe était dieu en lui était la vie et
la vie était la lumière des halles et la
lumière luit dans les textes
vous travaillez avec quoi des couleurs
de base le jaune est bien le bleu puis
c'est toi non nous avons des couleurs
vinyle et puis aussi des poudres donc je
veux dire comme couleur oui alors
évidemment il ya les couleurs primaires
de base et on fait nos mélanges
nous-mêmes pour obtenir des tons chair
et chacun sa gamme de couleurs suivant
sa façon de travailler
alors si tu as fait un petit pont cher
moyens
d'abord medapps john un petit rouge la
sauce vous ne vous en dévoile un peu
frustré vous n'aimeriez pas faire de la
peinture quand enfin sur les toiles
exposées
non il ya un peu au kilomètre carré
c'est à dire que nous préférons faire
une bonne tête de belvito ou deux
batteurs connu il soit connu ou pas ils
ont un bon document une belle tête de
femme ça nous plaît
et
et dieu créa ursula bons rails c'est un
art populaire nord un art de la rue mais
anarchy est présent aussi bien niveau de
la couleur que d'illustration est-ce
qu'ils empêchent tout de même pas une
certaine rigueur à on est tenu par ceux
de polichinelle important on est tenu
par une campagne publicitaire qu'on est
à suite d'une campagne publicitaire qui
se passe au niveau de la presse au
niveau de la fichage public y est longue
la retrouve exactement le même thème que
vous n'êtes pas livrer votre inspiration
n'ont actuellement pas larmes sont là
dessus avait presque été créé par un
maquettiste bien précis et on doit
suivre aussi très souvent au niveau des
illustrations aussi au niveau des textes
on alain pons des grandeurs vol et non
par une année contre à des obligations
de billing des pourcentages et 75% pour
intel par rapport à untel et c'est très
très surveillé est très important mais
ce qu'on ne paierait pas certains
acteurs en leur assurant alors la fiche
par exemple ça se peut sûrement arriver
en contrat et vous savez combien de
cinéma tchèque 150 par semaine
encore un bon pour peindre une toile
comme celle ci il faut environ deux
jours
oui puisque je ne suis pas à une annonce
près je ne ferai pas un dessin d'une
peinture mais je vous dirais qu'après
antenne de midi demain donc en direct du
vatican le soir cartes sur table
émission de jean pierre elkabbach et
alain duhamel sera consacrée aux
découvertes de la biologie moderne des
découvertes qui à la fin de ce siècle
sont susceptibles d'entraîner des
modifications profondes de
l'organisation et du fonctionnement de
notre société c'est pourquoi il y a un
an
le président de la république avait
demandé à trois biologistes de lui
établir un rapport qui lui permettront
demain matin et demain soir donc ces
trois spécialistes les professeurs
françois gros françois jacob prix nobel
et pierre royer seront les invités de
cartes sur ta c'est le cheval rien à
voir avec le sujet précédent c'est le
cheval fabrice temps qui a gagné
aujourd'hui le prix la haye jousselin
cette information je la tiens de la
bouche même de léon zitrone qui a
également assisté au tiercé dans lequel
on a vu une déroute des favoris est une
grosse surprise à l'arrivée lyon à 11
cents mètres de l'arrivée mindanao
l'once kazakh baies rouges mènent devant
mme hervé casaque jaune vrai jumping
vert foncé et la somme à amiens casaque
orange qui à l'extérieur là bas vous le
voyez va tenter de passer elle passe trè
jumping elle passe mais revêt elle passe
mindanao
on n'a pas encore parlé je le dis quand
les chevaux sont des réfugiés ou encore
danse du dernier tournant on n'a guère
parler n'est guère vu et rico et ni
duncan mais il est vrai qu'avec 67 kg il
avait une tâche difficile dans un
terrain très lourd ne leur jetons pas la
pierre
et ils feront mieux les chevaux pour le
sprint final ça veut dire les deux
derniers obstacles se partagent tant de
go payer à ceux qui vont à droite c'est
à dire mindana websérie martel en rouge
quoi bleus-là gaz lac de ce désert mais
ceux qui vont à gauche le long de la
ligne
du puzzle de la liste du pesage et
celles à samara qui va sauter en tête la
dernière et elle appartient à monsieur
ce call cac et les montées par jour n n
est entraînée par pierre ou bien encore
elle va gagner facilement tandis que
pour ma deuxième place
traille jumping en kazakh foncé va
prendre l'accessit devant le 11 mindana
d'un tiers émirats paru complètement g
par le thé le tiercé ma foi des rapports
devrait s'inscrire sur votre écran 16 17
11 des voici dans l'ordre 54 1831 froid
c'est un bon tiercé
il est vrai qu'avec la déroute des
favoris annoncés par daniel bilalian
ça ne pouvait guère faire - 9229 sens
bien à la météo vont terminer demain
matin une zone de temps doux couvert et
pluvieux se situera de la vendée au
centre au bassin parisien et à la
frontière belge en soirée ce mauvais
temps aura gagné les régions allant des
pyrénées au massif central et aux alpes
à l'arrière de cette zone comme on dit
dans les communiqués militaires un temps
frais et variable avec des averses
s'installera sous des vents de
nord-ouest modéré
le mistral et la tramontane souffleront
en soirée.les températures minimales
seront en hausse les maximales varieront
peu voilà une météo bien complète
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur antenne 2 dernier journal en fin de
programme avec pas là ma bonne soirée
bonsoir